okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about the
future of data set um and in particular
its user interface this is actually
going to be after we've just wrapping up
version 12 and this will be for version
12 one we hope um so Christy wanted you
want to first start off with a demo of
what you've done and then we should dig
into the more of the details yeah yeah
okay go ahead
go ahead and share my screen yep okay so
last time I showed you rows displayed
columns displayed let's take a look
again I mean let me okay what's going on
so this is just an option that controls
you know says just play three roles
three rows and then columns displayed
does the same thing with columns I mean
I think this UX is a little bit
confusing by now with the pagination UX
and the yeah we need to discuss that and
I have and what do we know about what's
going on with the cloud for example you
mean as far as controls go on the cloud
I haven't I mean there are some
differences in the code I haven't
attended to those yet like okay but I
mean you think basically this
functionality will work in the cloud
yeah yeah okay including the only real
issue with the cloud is some controls
need to be different but you know as far
as okay the scrolling goes is the same
okay now let me ask you another question
in in right now these are in memory back
datasets yeah in the future we expect
that there will be data sets that will
load stuff from files and things like
this okay correct I mean you know about
this so you don't know about this okay
yeah you know this is something we
discussed at some point the database
integration folk are sort of involved in
that and I think it'll be worth a
discussion with them I mean that that's
basically the backend plumbing for this
and my expectation would be that like
other things where like
audio for example you will sometimes get
that kind of footer on the UX on the UI
that says this is not stored inside the
notebook you know press here to store it
inside the notebook I know what I'm
saying yeah
and I think that's the same kind of
thing that we should be doing with data
set okay okay but anyway that's okay so
to keep going here so that's what all
those dashes and X's and things after
that I'll get to that though those are
just provisional controls for doing
sorting and hiding let's call them okay
okay okay that's just both and then the
frame style option so you would said you
had had a frame color option on your
agenda but I change it yeah nice umm
that's nice but that's a single frame
style so what would happen if I wanted
to go at different levels right we need
to talk about that I have an agenda item
for that okay
okay so this is a new stuff an item
display function so this is a function
which is applied to each content item
before it's displayed so it's basically
it's like its Maps path to its platform
well so what I've implemented is if you
just get a function on the right hand
side it applies globally if you give a
list of pairs with the path and then a
function it applies the past if it
applies a function to pass and match
that path pattern and first match wins
so the earlier things override the later
things yep so you can see I'd like a
replacement rule
it just says given this Paul yeah I mean
it's interesting because I sort of a
missing function it's like map hat but
well actually no replace part would work
though it is it's a rap it's a replace
map today yeah right yeah I'm surprised
we've never needed that function now
that I think about it so this is a
function which given oh I see why we
don't usually use it because because
usually
the thing what's happening here is that
it says that this level do this but it
isn't doing the thing where it says it's
not applying a function f inside the
expression tree that then effects all
sub trees of that tree it is merely
operating at that level is that correct
I mean in other words if I sit it's
applying to every individual element
whose path matches that path pattern so
it's not applying to like branches of
trees it's the trying to it's only
applying to the leaves that have those
paths mm-hmm so now the next question is
why what about a query string I mean
could I say you know highlight all
numbers in other words this is a I mean
I think your what you're doing is right
here I think this is not it's not useful
to do the other kind of thing I do think
this would be a yeah I mean I'm
wondering whether this is also something
that would be relevant to grid and
things like that
um yeah well yeah possibly yeah it would
give you more flexibility you know and
grid things are more straightforward cuz
you just rows and columns yeah well what
what features does grid have that data
set does not have in terms of formatting
background option alignment and so forth
I think all those things are easily
generalized to data set if we use this
notation with a path on the left-hand
side I see I see because in a grid it
can do essentially I mean has this
slightly hard to understand row column
mechanism yeah I think this is actually
better and I think this is easier less
obscure much less obscure actually and
particularly nice is that on the left
hand side there as you've shown you can
have association keys as well as part
numbers which is something not relevant
to grid as such right and that brings up
another issue so if you hover over
something the annotation shows you one A
two A which is not compatible with map
indexed map
would wrap those things with key so what
I've implemented you can either have a
if you haven't think there's a
non-integer
that's equivalent to that thing naked
and that thing wrapped with key and
similarly if you have key that's
equivalent to that thing or just the
argument of key
well it's appointment won't match either
one why are you telling me this I mean
so in other words if you right-click
there you can get a copy of the path is
that right yeah can you show that copy
position to clipboard okay but that's
course not what's shown in the
annotation down you know down here maybe
we should have a thing where we say copy
path to keyboard and copy position to
keyboard or something some way of
allowing you to get both of those cuz I
can imagine that there are cases where
that key thing will be annoying and not
worth having and by the way in terms of
the data set you don't need those if
those are wor strings you don't need
that to extract that elements of the
data set you could use you know apply to
one comma quotes a quotes to quote a
right but the question is what's that
left-hand side matching is it matching a
naked string or as a matching the string
Mac mesh or rap was key I am let's go
what's it going to be fed and I've just
implemented it so it'll match either one
I think it's the right thing to do I
think that's the courtesy thing to do
because what else could it mean I mean
in other words I there are cases where
you could conceivably have a majority
but I think they're few and far
mean in other words if it's a I think
it's okay is there in fact ambiguity I
don't believe so unless you have a key
that's named key of such-and-such which
is very which is you know one of those
quoting with quote things it's never
gonna work okay so my first comment to
my comment here is in that right-click
menu or whatever mechanism we have and I
don't know what we're doing with
right-click on mobile for example I'm I
don't know
I mean arguably what happens if you
Mouse down to that one I say if you
mouse over that that's where your mouse
stand so you don't get to go ask what
that is the only way you have
controlling things so the only way we
could do in a mobile would be to have a
tongue stick itself out when you mouse
over this when you touch the three to
have it bring up for example if you hard
press three it could bring up some kind
of from menu there that's probably the
right way to do it that hard press is
the analog of right click so make sense
yeah okay keep going this is quite
beautiful so far so one thing I
considered was that if a short hand
where if if you just admit this trailing
pattern that it just matches that branch
the you know the two branch but I
rejected that because that would mean if
you specify if you specify something
like this which is intended to apply to
leaves named a it would also apply
higher up on the tree yes so I rejected
that idea I may be kind of nice to have
that convenience but it would be
confused how nice is it I don't know how
nice it is I mean it's it's just you
know you just mean you do this I
wouldn't worry about it I wouldn't worry
about it I think it's okay I think by
the time you're you're controlling this
it's better to have explain it's better
to be explicit I think the mistake
probably with Grid is that it's too much
you know too many bizarre sort of
telling jokes by numbers type stuff um
okay
let's keep going all right so header
display function is the same thing
except it applies to the headers what is
a header so a header is basically keys
right it's it's a yeah
hello I think there's a question or
whether we should also have headers for
array indices but that's another that's
another agenda item upstairs
okay but but so what happens if I want
to change the background color of this
for example let's say I want to change
the background color of a whole um I
want to change all of the two subtrees
background color right you so you were
you wouldn't do that with a header
display function you'd do that with the
background option and a path which
describes that subtree where's that okay
but but then what about if I wanted to
change the color of the background to
the word tune that sits up there did you
say the same color as the - no no I'm
saying no no just change the color
there's a there's a background there
yeah this gray background
yes what happens if I want to change
that
well you can't currently not with the
header display function no I understand
but it was so it would be background
arrow list and then like - - - comma -
arrow background color I was done you
could try it
show me well I don't have that
implemented I don't have a background
function background option implemented
yet okay I mean it would essentially be
the same as this except this would be
background and this have we done that
before having background have have
things that have paths in them to do sub
backgrounds effectively I don't know if
grid allows you to do a grid allows you
do that somehow I think you can give
indices arrow color I believe or grid
what we should look that up okay
actually hold on just one second I will
be right back
just a second
okay I thought that so what did you find
great well so here's the here's the
syntax for grid this is the horizontal
vertical specs and then the list of
rules for individual elements it's
pretty wacky I mean yeah I don't quite
Eva
oh I see it that blue on top of green so
this is for specifying I think
individual rows specifying individual
columns and you can give a list oh I see
so if you say green red have you have to
need a bigger grid just to identity
matrix of whatever so now go I mean that
looks bizarre that looks like it's a
blue red blue come yeah yeah okay now
what happens and then I think if you do
that in another level of braces it will
repeat this one yeah okay I mean clearly
in your pattern thing we could do an
even queue yeah um okay so we want some
background thing that is like this
although perhaps we can generalize I
don't know how we can do this compatibly
but but um okay
I mean presumably presumably the
right-hand side well in the background
after in the right-hand side could be a
list of colors which functions the same
way this does with successive vitamins
that items at the left hand side mashes
understand what I mean mm-hmm
say that again so for example if you
give
a path specifies a column here and then
you say blue purple then it would
ultimately color the noise purple blue
purple you know it might be nice I mean
okay look one big question is you know
right now you've got three generations
table form
well actually four generations table
form grid data set formatting and tab
and table view right yeah what is our
strategic idea for what we're gonna do
to merge those like so with all of you
is now documented right I mean it's not
it's not it's now it's been there for
like nearly ten years but it's never
been officially but table view allows
editing doesn't it so I mean what's
interesting about that is we need to
understand how to merge that idea with
data set because having a data set
that's editable will be really cool yeah
um so what other functionality is table
you have that would be interesting and
there's this collapse headers thing what
does that do it just hides the hides the
headers I never seen that control before
you can the pops up when you select
something ah well and I don't know
whether it whether it allows I mean I
think it was supposed to have sorting
capability I mean this is really very
you know spreadsheet like that was kind
of the idea um I don't know what
put a string in that try it not right at
him
try judging tomorrow
I can't triple click try editing
elsewhere try adding in another cell aha
that's why
extra cells what well I wondered why I
didn't crop it to the content of the
month like a spreadsheet yeah
now did input form oh yeah that's
interesting and tried to be very clever
however I recognize that this turned
into a number mm-hmm I mean an
interesting question is whether this
should be viewed as more like a form
field I mean I think there's a value to
having these things which are you know
like a spreadsheet sort of
oversubscribed over over padded
collection I don't know why table view
is now finished I think there's an
argument we should try and finish it and
maybe what we should do is that you can
basically say data set of table view and
it will convert it to a data set and the
table view should be and arguably like
table view of a data set would convert
it to this form where you can do editing
well except that that doesn't apply
generally I mean no I know yeah so we're
just complain if it's not a rectangular
just put the thing in as its raw you
know sub matrix into that cell will be
my yeah there spanning column so it can
be spanning columns um what kind of
split will spanning columns we're been
on our live stream is asking can you
delete rows in table view that's a good
question try it not with the Delete key
menu okay so that's something that is
clearly something will be desirable for
this yeah I mean the question is should
we view this kind of input-output I mean
like input field is a different thing
from just typing something on in and
maybe this should Sonali review is
different from data set I'm not sure but
I do think it's time for us to finish
this um I mean I certainly would have
used this sort of variety of times to
just enter you know I mean we have this
mechanism for entering a matrix but I
think this is better well it's probably
better yeah there been many times when I
wanted spreadsheet functionality well
how much spreadsheet functionality well
I mean it would be nice to have full
spreadsheet functionality with the
ability to attach functions to things
yeah but then you've got something so
then that's completely different from
data set at least because then it's
basically yeah okay all right what's
what would you show him well so I said
that um data sites sometimes have
spanning columns like this one is that a
spanning column or is that just
something what's missing there oh wait a
minute that so that one main no it's
spanning because it's there's two
columns here and they're joined these
two columns are joined I don't think
that's the case I think what it is is
that there is no proof field there is no
proof element for hypothesis I know but
but
but in the structure that bill so what's
building here is actually a grid I mean
behind the scenes and in that grid this
is a spanning column so if you were
gonna translate this to a table view I
guess you would have liked to empty a
JSON empty elements or something I don't
know why you do that because because
then what I would see in this case No
well okay it the question of
two-dimensional flattening to go to a
table view is an interesting question I
think that's a yet different I mean that
that's one way to do it is to is to
flatten to 2d another way to do it that
is to take the visual thing flatten to
2d another possibility will be to take
the logical thing flatten to 2d just the
top two layers and everything else is a
sub sub array I say but let's go back to
your main discussion I mean okay so you
asked about these controls and the
headers those are just provisional
buttons to do these things so you can
really see them hide you know hide
columns I don't yet have that
implemented for higher levels but that
one should certainly work too you should
be able to collapse this whole thing but
what did I hide there I didn't hide the
two well I understand what am i hiding
so it's hiding this column it's oh wait
a minute but it isn't but I'd mmm that's
all that mess what would you say when
when if you've had well what I did
actually implement is it gives you an
ellipsis here but I don't know why I'm
not seeing it here it gives you a
minimum width minimum width thing I mean
that's that's the point is a minute you
know to take a less screen real estate
these should have changed I don't know
why they're not something's out of date
okay okay show me the other one the
under school and then that's that's for
sorting right now I just let me give a
better example
right now it just cycles through sorted
reverse sorted unsorted and you can do
the same thing for keys I anticipate
these things which way is it sorting the
keys in the the horizontal the vertical
keys yeah
the cut is sorting these elements by
this element this column no I get that
but if I wanted to sort the columns you
you've got that that that first
underscore the first one there sorts the
key in whatever it towards the rows by
key good so then okay now but what if I
want you to sort the columns by key do
you want to sort you want to rearrange
age height and weight by the there's no
provision for that I mean it certainly
could be a control here that does well
in the dot in this header why would that
make sense I mean in this case it
doesn't make sense
I mean so you want to sort the columns
by what yeah maybe you have to sort of
by no I mean I mean one possibility is
okay so they're the same thing that
you're doing four columns
I could do four rows yeah I could
support sort by the Jim Rose column
values right I could sort columns by the
Jim Rose values right
in which case there would be a sort
control here that's what that would mean
right but in the top left hand corner
there's an ambiguity because there
should be two sort controls there one
for vertical and one for horizontal know
the horizontal depends on the row right
you get different potentially different
sword if you sort by Donna then if you
sort by Lou no I understand it but I'm
saying you could sort by the keys of the
columns oh I see
I see what you're saying just as you're
sorting by the keys of the rows yeah
except that's always I mean in this case
for example here if you click here what
happens to these B and C elements they
don't have
they don't have headers at that level
right so you don't sort at that level so
we just sort within the a but then if
there were one control here and the B
had sub levels how do you say sort sort
the A's by columns or sort the B's
columns
well the control will be one level up
well you're saying that here you have a
control here for these columns mm-hm
if you had a control here for these
columns how would it know whether you're
intending to sort the A's or the bees
columns
what do you mean the A's will B's
columns it could sort one two and three
in a or it can sort one two and three in
B if they were there they're not in this
case but if they could be I understood
so you were saying if I had if I so if I
have a horizontal control here is
support it sorts these columns these
these things by key right yes if I had
an analogous thing here in this position
no I get what you're saying that I don't
see how to resolve that immediately yeah
okay um let's keep going okay I think I
understand I mean so there's some
questions here but let's go ok well
that's that's what I have to show what's
implemented okay and when I've done when
I've done is sort what does that mean
for the data set if I do shift enter on
that sorted data set what will happen
[Music]
it's currently just a display thing it
does it on the fly when it's displaying
it doesn't actually sort the original
data right so that's analogous to a
manipulate will you move the slider in
the NIP you late and then the question
is do you get it's that just a surface
level change or does that change the
underlying structure and for manipulate
we have this notion of a control that
says paste this does that make sense
yeah so I can imagine a similar thing
here that most
what you do is purely sort of display
level but there is a mechanism that says
okay I'm going to I want to paste a copy
of this that I can then use for the
future yeah you sound skeptical yeah I'm
just wondering if that would be
confusing I suppose not
why would it be confusing I mean because
that then you've changed the data set
yeah yeah although I mean the appearance
of the data set which has actually
changed and the one that is just sorted
on the fly is I guess there would be an
indicator a sorted it will be an
indicator which would shows a difference
am um okay let's let's go back to the do
you want to go back to the main agenda
here yeah so you um back to yours no not
yet what what things that were in my
notes have you not done or do what my
notes
inchoate well they were pretty sketchy
let me I can pull them up here
[Music]
absolutely nuts yes yeah I have my
annotations okay let the original okay
so I'm not sure what that is so short
form I haven't implemented that but
that's clear there's this well there was
some discussion last I'm not obviously
good oh there was some discussion about
whether we really wanted to do there was
intended to be show ten rows right mhm
vitaliy was suggested that was more
there was more valuable use for that
notebook level stuff I haven't
implemented so this is not implemented
but it's clear what it means pagination
I don't think there's any use for
pagination but we should talk about that
this is implemented without this dataset
style options wrapper this is
implemented yeah okay anything else on
this page I think these are just now
just kind of random I don't know what
these are they're just random that
things from the data repository I think
and yeah okay okay so one of my concerns
is actually if we get style if we get
some style sheet options then for
example for the data repository shingle
pages we can set um things to be um you
know we can set it so that we will
always get five rows or something yeah
okay let's go do you want to give me
control back okay okay so by the ways a
couple of comments on the live stream
here then is suggesting that just doing
shift enter on the output well what
happens I should know this but what
happens if you do the following so let's
say I get a manipulate okay I get this
manipulate and I do shift down to yeah
it does that yes I mean so in other
words it is burning in the output the
output settings so if I then say
settings of this setting of that it'll
be that right so that's probably the
right the same behavior that should
happen with um you know data set if you
take this output data set and you do
shift enter evaluation on it
when it is in the state you know the
sorted
state so to speak now I don't know what
the front-end plumbing necessary to make
that work well there's two ways we could
do that we could either reorganize the
original data or we could have an option
which says you know sort on this column
so we just set that option yeah that
moment doing the option I mean no the
option could then have it be represented
with a sort arrow for that column and so
on yeah yeah but nevertheless we could
have the data set query language
understand that option is that what
you're suggesting you mean if you index
the second element that you get the sort
the sorted second element that's what
I'm suggesting yes I suppose I would
have to do that yeah um okay
seth is suggesting a data set theme
which I agree with I mean that's what
once we have all these different
settings we can we can invent I think we
should have a data set theme um it's
possible that we're going to a point
where we should have a general theme
option um okay
and is asking about preventing long
values from truncating when viewing the
data set yeah that is a complicated
issue have you have you had thoughts
about that yet now but do you imagine I
mean if I make you know um and I make
this into a data set I have no idea what
its gonna do it may be a big mess yeah
okay so there's a couple of issues here
I mean do you imagine that you know do
you imagine that you're gonna do the
same thing of it going off the
right-hand side of the page or not and
what's cool yes except that now we also
have elision the ability to hide columns
and the ability but you've got a
horizontal scrollbar what's the
relationship during the horizontal
scrollbar and this and this kind of
thing well the way it's currently
implemented the the width of the column
is decided in a ten
I think the width of the window so I
mean it dollar does has changed though
your window into the the view it doesn't
actually change the like the widths of
columns or anything so it weighs thing
so okay so there's a couple of things
could happen here I mean these columns
could wrap okay or and I don't know I
mean doesn't grid have a way of doing
that with item size I believe so you
know what happens if you wrap that with
grid does it I don't think it does
nothing useful but we can try no it
doesn't that probably does should do
something useful um depending one
possibilities you can wrap it another
possibilities you can have a horizontal
scrollbar
and another possibility is what it's
doing right now a horizontal scrollbar
you mean like a local scrollbar yeah
like the one that you were showing me
well that's a global one for the whole
day to send know that I mean that that
one it's not as the one in the whole
window because here I'm not getting one
money-getting want the whole window
right you're talking about get like seen
like viewing the entire data set but if
you want to view a truncated individual
item no I'm suggesting but have scroll
bars there's different levels okay yeah
level one scrollbar for the whole window
okay level two scrollbar for the data
for the complete data set level three
score bra for that row of the data set
probably not a good idea no that doesn't
seem very useful fair enough and um
the final level would be you know
forcing wrapping because I think if I
take this and what happens if I say make
that you know partition that
let's say in fives um and then let them
it's a grid of that okay that's what it
does
oops okay so that's another possibility
that was your first possibility wasn't a
trap yeah I know another
ability is allied I mean no possibility
here is that we could put what amounts
to a short here I wasn't implying enough
but let's say short I don't know whether
this works does that work yes
like that okay now a thing that we've
wanted for a long time is shorts that
you can click on to get them to open up
um let's see
yeah so Bennis is saying that if he has
a string in a data set he'd like to be
able to set the truncation to start
after some number of characters so
that's effectively like this I mean we
could you know short is a very old
function and probably should be
modernized but um okay so I mean one
could imagine some kind of truncation
function one could imagine just wrapping
short by the way do I have a splice to
store stuff about this it's under data
set and a stove not
the okay we're getting support on the
live stream for the idea of some kind of
truncation function or some mechanism
like this but I can see this is going to
be useful because you want to have I
mean the best thing would be a specified
level of truncation together with
clickability to open this out that will
be the that will be the luxury version
in my view yeah so I'm just wondering
how this truncation function different
than item display function you could
consider it is I'm not sure it is it's
it's item display function
I suppose you yeah you might want
something to be independent of each
other and what sense well you can
specify you know it gets it very complex
if you essentially have to take the
cross-product of whatever styling you do
with the item display function and the
truncation function well unless the
truncation is always typically short
unless the truncation is very
straightforward unless we make a
function that is a smarter version of
short which we certainly could so that's
all you're doing so you just say item
display function arrow so now what are
you putting in the item display function
again so it can either be a function
which applies to every entry or it can
be a list of paths arrow function which
applies to things that match that path
applies to leaves whose path matricide
pattern okay well so I think that I
think that really just says we should
make a more sophisticated version of
short and put it in the item display
function if that's what you want now
there's a question of what the default
should be okay right
and I think the default should have some
level of shorta fication so to speak um
because I don't think it's not very
useful to have something where it's just
way too long now um you know should we
should we have any kind of wrapping by
default I don't see why we shouldn't I
mean you could certainly implement this
this is just using grid functionality
here so I mean grid I believe has an
item size option right um
sowhat's items style compared to what
you're talking about
well presumably it's I mean it's not a
function it would be a directive right
it's the right hand side also spacings I
mean I don't know whether you're how are
you covering that I have an address Sam
okay
dividers I don't know whether you can
add these things in but um I certainly
think about each one alignment is
another thing yeah by the way and this
is a thing for Sushma I mean I why
there's braces are oversized I have no
idea it's some kind of bug associated
with the fact that there was a
hyperlinks inside I think okay I do
believe that we might as well you know
we really should support a lot of the
styling that's in here yeah okay so
let's go back to pagination and whether
that's some value to it let me mention
one other issue while we're on this item
display function so we format dates and
entities in a special way within data
set and the question is if you have an
item display function how does that
interact with those defaults presumably
you want the item display function to be
fed the original data I think that right
but then that means if you specify an
item display function you've lost for
example the special formatting of dates
and entities so I'm not quite sure how
to address that
I mean one possibility would be to
provide a data set for data set form or
something that does the formatting as in
as it would be in a data set I don't
know very much um is there a way of
checking that the result of the function
is a style and if it's not then it goes
to a default well the problem is like
let's say you want to make all the
elements in a row green if you do that
then suddenly your dates will not be
formatted as yeah right so item display
function so the problem is we got to
compose these two functions so you're
saying to make everything green you
would do this right yeah correct yeah
and and the issue is humph and currently
that doesn't even work for I mean if you
were to wrap that around the format
identities and dates they wouldn't turn
green because I have explicit colors in
them yeah I'm sorry I'm just reminded of
my fine youngest son's characterization
when he was younger of bad science
education things which mostly were and
then it turns green and explodes anyway
okay so the problem is we've got we've
got a default item display function that
applies to certain things we want this
item display function to apply to the
raw date not to the dressed date but
then well we've got a similar kind of
issue with things like base style versus
other kinds of styling don't we isn't
base style addressing some of the same
issues base style specifications because
it's saying well I'm not sure if it is
I'm not sure if it is because it's
trying to give an overlay style
humpf I mean summation my data set form
would work I don't really like it I mean
it's kind of seems kind of hacky exactly
I mean it would work if you remember to
put it in there okay so what idea I had
was to provide the the function with the
third argument which is the default
formatted form so you could get the raw
date and you would also get the way the
data set would format date that would
kind of work except that currently that
that formatted date includes an explicit
color so you wouldn't turn green in this
case unless you go in and unwrap the
color which gets really missing you know
yeah well that's hopeless I mean that's
hopeless that will be this okay the
issue is okay for something like
graphics there is a notion of a sequence
of directives and you know the last one
wins basically
and that's what items style if it was
pure styling that's what I can style
would do what does what is the for
hunting of date what does it actually do
um well I haven't looked at the code but
it just turns it into a string and gives
it an explicit gray color okay maybe I
mean because there's a lot of other
formatting
I mean look look let me give you an
example okay so let's say that I say
something like um it's a good example
there are things which autoformat like
like um I can I do a style around an
image you know if I have a bunch of
images right if I say random image um
what will happen if i whoops what do I
want to do here that right okay great so
let's say I say that and I say table of
that comma five okay they will Auto
smallify themselves yeah
right now I would claim that if they had
Styles wrapped around and I don't know
would even do that in this case I good
question what's that you can wrap a
style around an image what does he do I
mean well des probably won't have any
effect I can't think of anything that
would have the baseline something some
kind of baseline for example yeah so
what would happen there so I would say
style there of baseline
position arrow random it doesn't think
it's an option there that's probably not
a style level option what is it an
option for typesetting Pacific things
like construct Sam yeah okay so it won't
allow me to do this but I mean my point
is I can imagine here and this is
something John would have more opinions
about I mean something where there's a
mixin of whatever the auto styling is
that causes this to get smaller because
that's effectively what you're doing
here you're you're stripping out random
chunk that's not needed I mean so if I
say entity list um I don't know um
elements I should get random list of
chemical elements let me say I say well
let's just say data set of that
yeah I mean that's definitely not
unreasonable what it did there but in
effect what that's doing is you know
that is analogous that is directly
analogous to what's happening here what
is the option that controls that that is
that an option to image that some kind
of auto display option image size
multipliers which is an option to what
it's a style level option okay then what
I'm claiming is that what we should have
is some kind of entity elision you know
for these things were we elide them that
we should have a style level option that
says whether to do the elision so what
I'm saying what are you calling a lesion
that your client is doing I'm the the
the the simplification okay they're
removing yellow boxes and so on yeah
right okay so I think this would work
okay so to listen to this so so
basically what we do is we define a
style option which controls the
formatting of things like entity yeah
okay and that style option is by default
set in data set if you don't like it you
can change that so that style option is
a mix into other things so the fact that
it's green you know we can decide to
what extent the greenness should flow
into in through that style option in the
case of a yellow box green this would
not flow through the yellow box so
you're saying that the the user would do
their formatting and then the code that
handles this special style would take
that formatting into account what I'm
saying is that's no no no
imagine image size multipliers okay yeah
so there is a default setting for image
size multipliers in the overall style
sheet that default setting causes images
to get smaller when you put them on a
table right right okay so similarly we
can imagine okay what triggers image
size multipliers well it's true
by the fact that the thing is seeing
itself in a sublist right so similarly I
would guess that data set might have I
don't even know what data set does if I
say data set of percent 36 what is it
gonna do okay so it has gone even
smaller by some miraculous cleverness of
some kind right so in other words it is
it is using something like image size
multipliers
I would think unless that's a hard code
hack so to speak but it could be using
so okay what triggers image size
multipliers answer you find yourself in
a list right that's the context right so
similarly we can imagine something that
is called something like I don't know
you know simplified formatting styles or
something bad name okay let's say let's
say I'm let's let's just imagine
minimized formatting style styles or
something and that and that could be
some whole Association of all kinds of
different things for different types of
it could be a list of patterns for
different types of things it's some
complicated thing I don't know exactly
what it is okay so what minimize
formatting Styles would do is it is
something that can be set they might
have some banks switched you know string
names it's something that is set at it
can be set at the style level for the
notebook that basically says by default
if you find yourself in an environment
for which you know this is specifying
given an environment what how should you
minimize a formatting of let's say
entity yeah so I think I understand what
you're saying but how would you use that
then to make dates format textually but
then turn green because you have an item
display function that says things green
well I'm saying that that yeah right I'm
saying this is something we obviously
have to write we have to decide how much
of the outside world the formatting
could seep in to what we have so for
example as I was mentioning
yellowbox entity you don't want it to
turn green I don't think I mean our
decision right but in the case of a
string a fide one you probably do want
to allow it to have the style to seep in
so so by default it was set its own
color to be some gray but it would the
code would look at the context and say
oh the colors explicitly set to green
sobs be green instead I'm thinking how
that would possibly work all right but I
mean we have a mechanism for that
because obviously there is a base style
and then you can have a style on top of
the base style right that's that that's
the meaning of base style is if nothing
else set got set then use this yeah it's
kind of the other way around now I mean
the issue here is that that the minimize
formatting style wants to set the color
explicitly to gray which means if you
specify something else it's not gonna
have any effect normally right well wait
a minute if I if I say okay so if I say
style of something so your claim is if I
say style of style of thing comma gray
comma green you claim this is going to
be gray right that's the fundamental
problem you're described yep
well okay an alternative to this would
be that you could go and monkey with
minimized formatting styles if you don't
want grey if you want something
different from grey well I didn't know
we did that if you um if you want
something different from grey then you
could change the minimized formatting
styles for entities for example yeah
but presumably you don't all you want to
do is say make it green instead of gray
you don't you don't have to mess with
all the other formatting that it's doing
by default right yeah I know
I think we should ask John he might have
an idea about this okay I I don't see
how to do this immediately ah Ben from
livestream is asking mouse-over would
help with dates and entities I mean I
think mouse-over what does mouse-over do
here that just tells us the position
yeah what what is why is this lost its
mouth so - so if I if I say um geo
nearest you know Timbuk - oops - your
nearest city Timbuktu five Wow um and
then I say data set of that okay so one
thing we've lost here is for this we
have a mouse over for the so we've lost
that mouse over yeah which is
unfortunate
I mean yeah look I do think an approach
like this is going to be sensible
because I think we're gonna need to
parameterize all these different things
that are you know specially formatted
here um I want to come back to the
pagination function thing so your belief
is there is no nothing useful of the
pagination function um no because I mean
you automatically get pagination
behavior if you specify a limited number
of rows or columns and you get the
arrows on the end of the scroll bars
which will you know advanced by pages
okay what does gallery view do for well
how does gather if you use pagination
all that does is alright tells you how
many items to display on a page it
doesn't really seem relevant to data set
well it does for a one-dimensional array
it might be relevant
Wilma you're saying when you say rows
and columns display function or display
rows displayed columns displayed by the
way I don't understand why that isn't
something that couldn't be at any level
like you have to say you know okay first
question is when you say rows displayed
what does that mean for a
one-dimensional list that's being
wrapped like this well in my prototype
it just displays three of those rows
with a scrollbar
okay so wrap first
so it's display rows not not rows in the
array elements in the array yes three
three rows of display okay question
though is if you have a more deeply
nested data set
don't you want a count of columns or
rows display at every level ooh
well I mean then have a scrollbar for
each one well you couldn't eat that
couldn't you
I mean what if I have this what if I
what if I for example say this thing I
mean I could imagine okay so let's let's
just do this percent forty one okay so
percent forty one percent um percent
thirty eight and then let's say in their
Association a goes two percent thirty
eight B goes to this C goes to percent
forty one this may be a horrible mess
what I'm going to get out from this now
I make a data set of that actually I'm
going to put I'm gonna put a brace
around here just to make another point
okay what on earth is going on here
so this did
no illusion you've got three columns
yeah and I have no mechanism for
specifying a lesion of that big mess
there and now if I say rose display
which I can't do here what an earth is
that going to refer to it's gonna refer
to the macro Rose here which is not so
useful and I think I'm the kernel
implementation doesn't even affect this
case they're only effects no I
understand because referring to a macro
row it's not referring to the micro rows
that are inside here you know to my mind
you know at every level there you know
there are rows there are columns there
are another level of row etc humph and
then there are implicit rows generated
by wrapping like this one here yeah and
a further complication is you don't
necessarily know if something is going
to be a row or a column depending on how
the datasets laid out but you do know
the level in the dataset yeah it's fair
to assume that you know that yeah um and
just like you could quite well give a
path yeah I mean you couldn't principle
give a path that says for example you
know this particular big blob but I only
want three rows displayed but another
thing I want five rows displayed and you
could do that with a path yeah now the
question is what is the relationship
between the elision operation and this
in other words there are there are in
principle three levels of illusion one
is you don't see anything you just see a
little little indicator you know at the
top of the column or something second
thing is you um sorry the second thing
is you you've seen
okay you can alight everything away you
can shorten what you have there right
with that illusion marker at the end
like sometimes it will display the first
five elements for column and then at the
six element is yes right right that's so
that's one form of illusion another form
of illusion is illusion where you have
the scroll bars and things yeah right
because that's a okay so what's the
trade-off between elision where it says
and ten more verses solution where you
can scroll to get those ten more so one
of the them is and ten more and you
click on the ten more and it opens up
and the other is all of them are visible
you just scroll through them well I mean
they really seem to be duplicate
functionality the only advantage of the
first one is you can change the number
of things you're displaying
interactively no I think it's nice and I
think that first one is very visually
nicer I think scroll bars are very very
heavy and should be avoided if one can
yeah I mean look the advantage of a
scroll bar okay the opener it's
basically like you're closed or you're
open that's it a scroll bar is like you
can scan through the whole list and I
think at any level a scroll bar could be
useful
you
you
I need to get going here um that this is
clearly I mean look we're making
progress I think the stuff you have is
quite good I think um you know this
whole question about elision we need to
think about a bit more systematically
and my feeling is that there really
should be two mechanisms for it one is a
short like mechanism that's in the data
okay yeah and the other is a a mechanism
that is from the control of um you know
you know what I'm trying to say from the
from the control
I'm not sure what you're trying to say
is is is from the options to the data
set that you're saying from the outside
I want to take this particular part of
the data set and turn it into an opener
or a scroller mm-hmm right so okay so
look both of those things both an opener
and a scroller could be achieved by
something in the data
I claim right short is the beginnings of
an opener type mechanism although it
works slightly differently but one could
imagine and a lighted thing which was
just a wrapper that could apply to any
expression that would simply display it
as you know here's a list and then it's
plus dot dot you know tell elements with
a little clicker on the ten elements
that would allow you to open it out
right when you say in the data you mean
actually in the content of the data set
well surely you don't know I don't want
that no I don't want that I mean I mean
okay I mean I mean it would be in the
options - yeah yeah in the options as an
overlay in the option saying yeah that's
what that's what I want
yes right so it'd be some mechanism to
to map you would give a path and then
the elision mechanism to apply to things
in that path or or the branch specified
by the path yes yes right exactly
um yeah okay look I need to go
unfortunately um this is this is good
this is nicely under steam so let's
let's um okay do you think you can you
know iterate a little bit more on this
design step
yeah and um let's let's pick this up
again in a few days and try and see if
we can nail it down but I'm glad to see
the progress that you're making um okay
okay thanks thanks to folks on the live
stream as well okay see y'all bye